nous accueillons neutralité du samedi 20
heures ce soir jean claude étienne
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
au moment où la première salle de
soudure et en france je voulais inviter
quelqu'un qui a été hué âgées d'une
salle de shoot en suisse voilà
jean-claude vous êtes né le 18 juin 1966
à bienne à 30 km de berne en suisse père
horloger chez oméga sont là bas ils sont
tous soient relogés non au prince comme
bien sûr
mère femme au foyer
vous avez 12 ans lorsque votre maman
tombe gravement malade cancer du poumon
c'était la personne dont j'étais le plus
proche de vous je souffrais mais je ne
pouvais pas le dire une famille on le
cache beaucoup ses émotions chez vous
voilà c'était pas tellement dans les
habitudes de parler ce contre de ce
qu'on ressentait ouais c'est vrai qu'à
ce moment là bas ce moment je me rendais
pas vraiment compte mais je suis resté
quand même beaucoup de choses qui j'ai
pas pu exprimer puis concept alors face
à la maladie qui s'installe au coeur de
votre foyer vous chercher un
échappatoire
vous commencez à traîner au parc à vélo
derrière chez vous ou fumer quelques
cigarettes
ouais bah je me mettais avec les eagles
qui les fumées
sortaient un petit peu de ce qui était
demandé à l'école quoi finalement vous
avait 14 ans quand vous enterrer votre
maman vous retrouvez seul avec votre
père à la maison là l'ambiance est assez
lourde bah oui voilà fectivement sert
son parti sont partis ils se sont mariés
à leur hobby ne faisait pas grand chose
à vous dire
on se parlait pas mal mais de trucs
alors vous allez mon concept ne parlait
pas de soi on parlait pas de ce conte de
ce qu'on ressentait les pas de nos
tristes sont parlait pas de
fais comme
difficile poule quoi lors de vos virées
au parc à vélos l'après midi vous passez
à ce moment là des cigarettes au
cannabis qu'aux films et des pétards
j'étais le début vous avez 15 ans quand
votre père décide de déménager à genève
et vous supportait très mal le passage
de la compagne à la ville vos notes à
l'école dégringole n'ai pas d'amis quoi
vous ne rêvez pas pour faire des amis
voilà c'est assez difficile parce que je
n'avais pas d'affinités avec mes
camarades de club et voilà c'est le
cannabis cas plus dessus lavours payer
sur vous même complètement à peine
arrivé à genève ou découvrent
effectivement l'équivalent du parc à
vélos de bienne ça s'appelle le jardin
anglais alors vous devenez un habitué de
ce rendez vous des fumeurs de joints
vous dites c'était un peu ma nouvelle
famille vous pouvez changer sur son nous
qu'on souffre finalement on peut sans
risque beaucoup se tournent beaucoup là
où tout mais j'avais plus de liens
effectivement avec les gens que je
retrouvais à la barre on ville qu'avec
ma propre famille mais pas très loin du
jardin anglais se trouve la place du
molard alors là c'est vraiment le haut
lieu du trafic de drogues dures à genève
à ce moment là ouais ouais c'est mon
aksas passeur
et un jour un pote vous propose de
sniffé de l'héroïne
votre descente aux enfers et commencez
vous accrocher peu à peu
persuadé que vous arrêterez quand vous
voudrez mais le jour où votre pote
arrête ses activités et arrête de vous
fournir vous comprenez la situation vous
j'ai découvert le manque à ce moment là
quand tout à coup le fournisseur n'était
plus l'homme du coup il fallait
on trouvait ailleurs que les halles et
place du molard et puis c'est cher et
puis a été différent l'ambiance était
différente aussi
et
là le truc tu as commencé à se tenir un
peu plus compliqué là vous avez traîné
place du molard et comme vous avez perdu
votre job impôts payés 2 0 jusqu'à 20 g
300 euros vous montez des arnaques qui
d'armes à quoi vous voulez un peu votre
famille vous tapez dans le porte monnaie
demeure
g20 voler à l'étalagé
fallait trouver des clients aussi pour
les dealers faire abattre asia ne vous
êtes pas dit leurs parce que vous avez
peur vous et rabatteurs pour les dealers
oui mais j'étais un très mauvais deal of
ages est un très mauvais businessman moi
je consommais toujours de rien donc du
coup ça voilà je me retrouvais vite
finalement retrouvé d'autres solutions
pour pouvoir assurer la console
avait 25 ans quand votre père par
s'installait l'étranger avec sa nouvelle
compagne vous retrouver tout seul à ce
moment là mais vous rencontrer une femme
vous mariez vous faites un enfant je me
suis dit génial j'ai une bonne raison
d'arrêter préserver un peu cette famille
construire quelque chose enfin quoi
et puis bah là ça commençait de pécloter
un petit peu parce que j'ai aussi perdu
mon job à ce moment là les fermes et
donc je me suis retrouvé au chômage le
chômage s'est terminée donc plus de
ressources c'est ma femme qui faisait
tourner un peu la marmite et c'est là où
j'ai changé complètement une mode de
consommation et je suis rentré vraiment
dans la consommation par injection oui
il en faut mois ouais
là vous décidé de vous faire aider vous
entamez un programme de sevrage à la
méthadone
mais vous continuez à prendre de
l'hérault en plus on m'a donné de la
méthadone pendant quelques jours
quelques semaines
et après voilà j'étais plus dépendants
allait remettre problème c'est que les
amitiés les habitudes êtes est toujours
bien là et
ça m'a pas sorti de sa pas réglé le
problème en fait à partir de là pendant
15 ans vous allez faire des cure
désintoxication et replonger en ressorte
et c'est une époque très difficile pour
vous parce que plus personne nous fait
confiance à ce moment là
oui et puis ça tout le temps ça va pas
ça va pas du tout donc je vais me faire
soigner je vais à l'hôpital je ressors
jeudi super match est abstinent tout va
bien je vais recommencer enfin faire
outre mon nom est en fait un cheval et
même changer les mêmes j'habite un jeu
fréquentent les mêmes lieux et du coup
ben voila je suis pas dans les mêmes
processus puis problème avec l'héroïne
c'est que ça devient le centre de votre
vie c'est à dire qu'on n'a plus envie de
manger on n'a plus envie de boire on n'a
plus envie de baiser on n'a plus envie
de sortir le matin quand vous vous
réveillez la première chose que vous
faites avant de prendre un café c'est un
shoot après 8 heures à 8 heures de
sommeil ben voilà c'est le monde la
veille il faut prévoir pour le lendemain
d'avoir sa dose la journée c
travail travail il s'est tourné pour
assurer sa console de la journée prévoir
pour le lendemain enfin c'est vraiment
un boulot à plein temps 7 jours sur 7 et
365 jours par an vous devenez un junkie
ordinaire ce qu on appelait
ça tournait vraiment là où touré en fait
à ce moment-là je l'utilisais nettement
plus de seringue que de fourchette et de
couteaux
et puis en 2001 une salle d'injection
une salle de shoot ouvre à genève son
nom quai 9 pour vous c'est le début d'un
long retour à la vie alors comment ça se
passe mais déjà on s'inscrit en quelque
sorte c'est à dire qu'on donne son nom
son âge on explique un petit peu aussi
bien son parcours et après on vous donne
un ticket de passage et là il faut
attendre évidemment parce qu'il n'y a
pas non plus tendre salle que ça donc
souvent des jeunes qui n'ont pas la
patience d'attendre donc ils vont sous
tes dans la rue devant n'importe quoi
oui ça aurait alors dans la salle
d'injection une fois que vous y êtes on
vous donne un kit stérile alors serein
il ya des aiguilles vous trouvez des
tampons alcoolisés pour se désinfecter
vous avez accès à un garrot s'il le faut
et vous avez quelqu'un qui est là qui
supervise en infirmier donc qualifiés
qui est formée à la réanimation aussi
jamais ya un problème donc la cia une
overdose il ya quelqu'un qui sait
comment on gère une overdose absolument
ouais ça fait une overdose dans des
toilettes publiques c'est vraiment il
n'a jamais eu de leurs douze mortels en
suisse dans les salles d'injection couet
dans les inconvénients mais c'est que ça
attire le trafic évidemment parce que
toute façon la salle de shoot elle peut
pas être très éloignée de l'endroit où
il ya le trafic parce que sinon agent
qui aurait pas la patience d'attendre
ban a justement c'est pas la salle de
shoot qui attire le deal c'est que la
salle de shoot s'implante là où il ya la
vie humble et toxiques ou alors à
l'époque où vous fréquentez sept salles
de shoot les conditions sont améliorées
mais vous êtes toujours héroïnomane
j'avais plus de 20 nos bras êtes obligé
de vous piquer dans les pieds certains
se piquent dans les parties génitales
choses qui peuvent arriver vous trouvez
plus vos veines quoi bout d'un moment
effectivement laisse bouffer par les
saloperies qu'on met aussi dans vous
achetez des ruines dans la rue
on n'a pas beaucoup en fait d'un paquet
way
ce n'est qu'en 2007 vous décrocherez de
l'héroïne pour la mettre la donne et
vous avez pris la médaille pendant
combien de temps après
je n'ai pris pendant pendant plusieurs
années ça m'a permis déjà de plus de
plus avoir un traficoter pour assurer la
consommation c'est à dire que le
problème le monde n'était plus un
problème ouais donc toute la petite
délinquance qui gravitent autour de
l'acquisition du produit déjà ça règle
le problème est là aujourd'hui on
prenait une héroïne née méthadone
libellules outre été quand même temps la
héroïne ça fait cinq ans et puis la
méthadone ça fait quatre mois vous
sentez comment la nôtre bien merci
alors l'autre jour
le jazz est allé manger une pizza avec
votre fille qui a 20 ans et elle vous a
annoncé qu'elle voulait rentrer dans la
police
je trouvais ça génial ou coincé quelque
part ben voilà on transmet pas forcément
les
problèmes qu'ont pu à sam a aussi
rassuré dans le fait que si elle suit
cette voie là ouais c'est que quelque
part elle part pas dans la conso être
qu'elle baissera au style
possible vous connaissez votre peur
conclusion la selle de shoot m'a permis
de décrocher et m'a rendu ma dignité ça
m'a permis
ça m'a permis beaucoup de
pouvoir gentiment réapprivoiser un peu
le bal le monde des vivants parce qu'on
est vraiment dans un peu un autre
c'était un lieu où
c'est un lieu de rencontres sociales ou
les gens du quartier la police les
usages et les travailleurs sociaux
parfois se mettent autour d'une table et
discuter du problème donc quand tout à
coup sur la table le problème du
matériel qui traînait dans le quartier
l'équipe qui gérait le lieu s'est dit
ben tiens et si on appliquait des
usagers dans le ramassage des seringues
autour et ça a permis comme ça de bannir
approprié un petit bout voilà un petit
job alors que ses succès passés pas le
temps pas ramasser des pompes mais là
bon voilà je pouvais tenir 2 commence à
tenir des horreurs à me sentir impliqué
dans quelque chose et un petit journal
il ya eu voilà il ya des choses qui
m'ont permis de me réapproprier un peu
de comptes certaine confiance en moi et
puis le fait que ben justement je ne
t'ai pas qu'une mère a loué à lyon vous
venez dans le temps que le témoignage de
jean claude etienne
comment pouvez vous vous opposez à la
création de salles de shoot en france
je suis heureux de voir que monsieur
s'en est sorti et je suis d'ailleurs
heureux de voir qu'on peut se sortir
d'une telle situation très difficile
l'héroïne serait déjà la première chose
mais si vous voulez moi ce qui me
préoccupe surtout c'est l'étendue des
dégâts de la drogue aujourd'hui en
france vous parlez des salles de shoot
qui sont dire un petit une petite chose
dans l'océan de la drogue aujourd'hui de
l'économie de la drogue aujourd'hui en
france très honnêtement je ne pense pas
que ça règle le problème de la
toxicomanie surtout surtout qu'il existe
déjà en france divers services et
notamment dans le milieu médical qui
sont qui ressemble beaucoup à ce que
vient de nous décrire je suis sûr que
c'est fait pour aider ceux qui sont
grevées 7 a fait pour empêcher les gens
de ce brevet ça c'est clair
la salle de shoot n'est pas une solution
c'est un élément qui fait partie d'un
tout et qui permet d'avancer un petit
peu de reconnaître déjà que la drogue
est un problème est qu'on puisse s'en
occuper très bien ça sera le mot de la
fin merci réaction de ne rien rater de
in a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus